Oggi voglio parlarti di qualcosa che
potrebbe sembrarti strano, quasi un
controsenso.
Per tutta la vita ci siamo sentiti dire
"Cammina, [musica] cammina più che puoi,
fa bene"
e nessuno lo mette in dubbio.
La passeggiata quotidiana è un rito
sacro, un momento per noi, per il nostro
cuore, per la nostra mente.
Quante volte dopo pranzo hai [musica]
preso il cappello e sei uscito a fare
due passi lungo il corso o nel parco
sotto casa, sentendo che stavi facendo
la cosa giusta e avevi ragione.
Ma se ti dicessi che è arrivato alla
soglia dei 70 o anche degli 80 anni,
insistere solo sulla camminata macinando
chilometri su chilometri potrebbe non
essere la strategia migliore,
anzi potrebbe addirittura mascherare dei
problemi che non stai affrontando.
Non sto dicendo di appendere le scarpe
al chiodo, assolutamente,
ma oggi insieme voglio esplorare un
territorio nuovo, un territorio dove la
qualità del movimento batte la quantità,
dove scoprirai due cose, solo due, che
la scienza più recente indica come
potentissime alleate per invecchiare non
solo bene, ma con forza, con equilibrio,
con una vitalità che forse pensavi di
aver perso. Preparati perché stiamo per
mettere in discussione una delle
convinzioni più radicate sul benessere
dopo i 70 anni e ti assicuro che alla
fine di questo video guarderai il tuo
corpo con occhi completamente diversi.
Partiamo da un fatto. Camminare è
un'attività cardiovascolare eccezionale.
Su questo non si discute, ma superata
una certa età, il nostro corpo cambia le
sue priorità e noi dovremmo fare lo
stesso. Pensa alle tue articolazioni,
alle ginocchia, alle anche. Hanno
lavorato per te per 70-80 anni. Ogni
passo che hai fatto nella tua vita ha
chiesto qualcosa a quelle cartilagini, a
quei [musica] tendini.
Continuare a sottoporli a uno stress
ripetitivo per ore, ogni giorno, senza
dare loro nient'altro, può portare a
un'usura che il corpo non riesce più a
compensare, come faceva a 40 anni.
È un po' come continuare a usare una
Fiat 500 d'epoca per lunghi viaggi in
autostrada. È una macchina meravigliosa,
ma ha bisogno di una manutenzione
diversa, più mirata, più intelligente.
E qui arriva il primo punto che forse ti
farà dire "Non ci avevo pensato".
La camminata da sola fa pochissimo per
contrastare uno dei più grandi nemici
silenziosi dell'invecchiamento, la
sarcopenia.
È una parola un po' tecnica, lo so, ma
indica semplicemente la perdita naturale
di massa e forza muscolare che avviene
con il passare degli anni.
Pensa che dopo i 60 anni il ritmo di
questa perdita accelera drasticamente,
arrivando fino all'1% di massa muscolare
persa ogni singolo anno.
Secondo la Cleveland Clinic, tra i 65 e
gli 80 anni si può perdere fino all'8%
di massa muscolare per [musica] decade.
E questo non significa solo sentirsi un
po' più deboli quando sali,
significa avere un metabolismo più
lento, un maggior rischio di diabete,
ossa più fragili e soprattutto una
minore capacità di reagire agli
imprevisti, come un gradino che non
avevi visto o un marciapiede sconnesso.
La camminata non costruisce nuova massa
muscolare, mantiene il cuore in forma,
sì, ma non costruisce. Ed è qui che
entra in gioco la nostra prima
rivoluzionaria cosa. La prima cosa che
dovresti fare è dedicarti a un
allenamento di forza. So cosa stai
pensando,
ma come alla mia età devo mettermi a
sollevare pesi come un ragazzino in
palestra.
L'immagine è sbagliata, ma il concetto è
giustissimo.
E qui devo essere sincera con te. Credo
fermamente che il più grande errore
della comunicazione sulla salute degli
anziani sia stato quello di parlare solo
di camminata, trascurando completamente
l'allenamento muscolare.
È stato un errore culturale enorme e i
dati lo dimostrano.
L'allenamento di forza per un
settantenne non è una gara di muscoli,
non è sudore e fatica, è un dialogo con
il proprio corpo per mantenerlo
reattivo, robusto e funzionale.
Studi recenti come quelli pubblicati
dalla Mayo Clinic hanno dimostrato che
un allenamento di resistenza mirato può
non solo rallentare, ma in alcuni casi
addirittura invertire i cambiamenti
nelle fibre muscolari legati
all'invecchiamento.
Hai capito bene? Invertire non è
fantascienza, è biologia.
E non si tratta di sollevare carichi
pesanti, a volte non si tratta nemmeno
di sollevare pesi.
Hai mai sentito parlare di esercizi
isometrici?
Sono contrazioni muscolari che avvengono
senza movimento articolare.
Immagina di spingere con tutte le tue
forze contro un muro. Il muro non si
muove, ma i tuoi muscoli stanno
lavorando intensamente.
Un esempio pratico e semplicissimo, il
wall sit, la sedia al muro. Appoggia la
schiena al muro, piega le ginocchia come
se fossi seduto su una sedia invisibile
e mantieni la posizione per 20-30
secondi.
Senti i muscoli delle cosce che
bruciano?
Quella è forza pura, costruita in totale
sicurezza per le tue articolazioni,
senza nessun impatto.
E adesso arriva il secondo Non ci avevo
pensato. Il British Journal of Sports
Medicine ha pubblicato uno studio che ha
dimostrato come gli esercizi isometrici,
in particolare il Wall Seat e il plank,
siano tra i metodi più efficaci in
assoluto per abbassare la pressione
sanguigna.
più efficaci della corsa, più efficaci
della camminata veloce.
Chi l'avrebbe [musica] mai detto che
stare fermi contro un muro potesse fare
più bene alla pressione di una
passeggiata di un'ora? Puoi usare delle
semplici bande elastiche, quelle che
costano pochi euro in qualsiasi negozio
di sport.
Puoi fare dei piegamenti sulle braccia
appoggiandoti al muro della cucina o
sollevare delle bottigliette d'acqua da
mezzo litro mentre sei seduto in
poltrona a guardare il telegiornale.
L'obiettivo non è la fatica estrema, ma
la stimolazione costante.
Due o tre sessioni a settimana, anche
solo di 15-20 minuti, possono fare una
differenza che la sola camminata non
potrà mai darti. Pensa alla sensazione
di portare le borse della spesa dal
mercato senza fatica. di alzarti da una
sedia senza dover puntare le mani sui
braccioli, di sollevare [musica] un
nipotino e farlo ridere senza sentire la
schiena che protesta. Questa è la vera
ricompensa, non un numero su una
bilancia, ma la libertà nei gesti
quotidiani.
E a proposito di gesti quotidiani, mi
piacerebbe sapere una cosa. Qual è
quella piccola fatica di tutti i giorni
che vorresti tornasse a essere un gesto
semplice? Aprire un barattolo, salire le
scale senza fiatone? Scrivimelo in un
commento. Confrontiamoci su questi
piccoli grandi obiettivi.
E ora passiamo alla seconda cosa,
qualcosa di ancora più profondo che ha a
che fare con la mente tanto quanto con
il corpo. Qualcosa che secondo me è il
vero spartiacque tra un invecchiamento
subito e un invecchiamento vissuto con
pienezza.
Hai mai pensato a come fai a sapere,
anche a occhi chiusi, se il tuo braccio
è teso o piegato?
O come riesci a camminare su un
marciapiede un po' sconnesso senza
guardare costantemente i tuoi piedi?
Questo è merito della propriacezione.
È una specie di sesto senso che permette
al tuo cervello di sapere esattamente
dove si trova ogni parte del tuo corpo
nello spazio in ogni istante.
È quello che ti permette di portare una
tazzina di caffè alla [musica] bocca
senza rovesciarla, di scendere un
gradino senza pensarci, di girarti
quando qualcuno ti chiama senza perdere
l'equilibrio.
Con l'età questo senso si affievolisce.
lentamente, silenziosamente
e quando si affievolisce aumenta
esponenzialmente il rischio di cadute.
I dati italiani dell'Istituto Superiore
di Sanità sono impressionanti e credo
che non se ne parli abbastanza. Quasi il
29% degli over 65 in Italia cade almeno
una volta all'anno.
Tra gli ultra ottantaccinquenni si
arriva al 31%.
Ogni anno nel nostro paese si registrano
circa 120.000 fratture [musica] del
femore tra gli anziani e il 40% degli
anziani vive con la paura costante
[musica] di cadere.
Questa paura a volte è quasi peggio
della caduta stessa perché porta a
muoversi di meno, a rinunciare alle
uscite, a chiudersi in casa, a perdere
l'indipendenza e le relazioni sociali. È
un circolo vizioso terribile.
La camminata su un terreno liscio e
conosciuto, come il solito percorso nel
parco o lungo il viale, fa molto poco
per allenare questo sesto senso, anzi lo
impigrisce perché il cervello va in
automatico, non deve più calcolare,
[musica] adattarsi, reagire.
Ecco perché la seconda cosa da fare è
dedicarsi ad attività che risveglino la
propria
e il re indiscusso di queste discipline,
quello che la scienza ha studiato più a
fondo, è il taic.
Non vederlo come una strana arte
marziale orientale, ma come una poesia
in movimento.
Movimenti lenti, fluidi, controllati che
costringono il tuo cervello a
ristabilire una connessione profonda con
ogni muscolo, ogni tendine, ogni
centimetro del tuo corpo. Uno studio
della Stanford University ha dimostrato
che la pratica costante del taicurre il
rischio di cadute fino al 58% rispetto
al semplice stretching. e un'altra
ricerca ha mostrato una riduzione delle
cadute ricorrenti fino al 70%.
70%
è un numero enorme che nessuna medicina,
nessun integratore, nessun paio di
scarpe ortopediche può promettere.
Ma non devi per forza iscriverti a un
corso di taici. Puoi iniziare con
esercizi semplicissimi a casa tua. Prova
a stare in equilibrio su una gamba sola
tenendoti leggermente a un tavolo o a
una sedia per 10 secondi. Poi cambia
gamba. Quando ti senti sicuro, prova a
farlo senza appoggio. Prova a camminare
lentamente per il corridoio, mettendo un
piede esattamente davanti all'altro,
tallone contropunta, come un funambolo
su una linea immaginaria. Oppure, e
questo è un consiglio che adoro, prova a
lavarti i denti stando su una gamba
sola. Sembra una sciocchezza, ma stai
allenando il tuo cervello a mantenere
l'equilibrio mentre è impegnato in
un'altra attività. è proprio eccezione
allo stato puro. E qui c'è il terzo non
ci avevo pensato. Allenare la
propriazione non migliora solo
l'equilibrio fisico. Uno studio
pubblicato su Plus One ha dimostrato che
la respirazione controllata e il lavoro
corporeo consapevole come quello del
taicorano
la concentrazione, riducono l'ansia e
soprattutto ti restituiscono una fiducia
nel tuo corpo che è impagabile. È la
sensazione di essere padrone dei tuoi
movimenti, non un passeggero timoroso. è
la differenza tra uscire di casa con il
timore di inciampare e uscire di casa
sapendo che il tuo corpo sa come
reagire. Quindi cosa abbiamo scoperto
oggi? che dopo i 70 anni il segreto non
è camminare di più, ma muoversi meglio.
Integrare la tua amata passeggiata che
resta un momento prezioso per il cuore e
per l'anima con queste due pratiche
potentissime.
Un allenamento di forza intelligente per
mantenere i muscoli tonici, reattivi e
capaci di proteggerti. È un lavoro
sull'equilibrio e la propria eccezione
per sentirti stabile e sicuro come una
quercia.
Non devi stravolgere la tua vita.
Non devi iscriverti in palestra, non
devi comprare attrezzature costose.
Si tratta di aggiungere, non di
sostituire.
Aggiungere 15 minuti di esercizi di
forza due o tre volte a settimana.
Aggiungere 10 minuti di esercizi di
equilibrio ogni mattina, magari prima di
uscire per la tua passeggiata.
Piccoli semi che giorno dopo giorno
faranno crescere un albero di benessere
robusto e rigoglioso.
Pensa agli abitanti delle zone blu della
nostra Sardegna, quei paesi
dell'entroterra dove vivono alcuni tra i
centenari più longevi del mondo.
Non passano le giornate a fare maratone
o a contare i passi su un orologio
digitale.
Si muovono costantemente, in modo
naturale e vario. sollevano pesi
lavorando la terra, si chinano, salgono
e scendono per i sentieri collinari,
mantengono il corpo attivo in tutti i
suoi aspetti e la genetica, come hanno
dimostrato gli studi, incide per meno
del 10%. Il resto è stile di vita,
movimento intelligente, alimentazione
sana e, non dimentichiamolo mai,
relazioni sociali forti.
Ecco, forse questo è il quarto "Non ci
avevo pensato." I centenari sardi non
fanno esercizio fisico strutturato,
eppure il loro corpo resta forte e in
equilibrio perché ogni gesto della loro
giornata è di fatto un allenamento
completo. La mia speranza con questo
video non è di darti una ricetta magica,
ma di offrirti una nuova prospettiva,
un invito a guardare al tuo corpo, non
con rassegnazione, ma con curiosità e
intelligenza,
a diventare l'architetto del tuo
benessere, costruendo un futuro in cui
ogni passo, anche se più breve, è più
forte, più sicuro e più pieno di vita.
Se hai trovato utile quello che ti ho
raccontato oggi, condividi questo video
con qualcuno a cui vuoi bene, qualcuno
che potrebbe averne bisogno. E non
dimenticare di raccontarmi la tua
esperienza nei commenti.
Hai già provato qualcuno di questi
esercizi?
Come ti sei sentito? Mi farebbe davvero
piacere leggere la tua storia. A presto.